get out of my room
get out of
my mind
[Music]
i let you feel what i could not provide
stripped myself off
[Music]
oh
i hide
but it's not your fault
i know you're not
[Music]
get out of my phone
get out of my
life
the storm has come to stay
through
the night
i'd like to say
it has been nice
been
lost for night's just
won't
suffice
but it's not my fault
i don't want to be a
cat
[Music]
yes i'll miss you though i know
you can't
[Music]
that's not like me
[Music]
there's more
to see
[Music]
than my
[Music]
[Music]
get out of my room
get out of my
mind
[Music]
i was just
when i saw you there you taught me
how to find sections that just don't
care through your lens i saw beauty
and hidden
ahead i couldn't help
[Music]
[Music]
in every shadow
cast
and the evil lies behind this leading
man take every
[Music]
is
[Music]
my hope it never felt
[Music]
or fight for freedom of system three
alongside such diverse
[Music]
this pirate ship will rise
[Music]
and once again
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
my
hello okay
for some real reason i don't know what
happened today but i turned on my
computer it happened at work as well and
like all of my software has just been
disconnected from my microphone i never
took this guy out so i don't know why
but anyway thank you mantas for letting
me know um
but yeah so i had a me and jamie were
talking about our soundcloud the other
day
and i was like you know what i
completely forgot that i have music on
soundcloud and
we haven't played it in so long so i
thought we would play the soundcloud
this uh this live stream
and yeah i can't wait for the day when i
can actually play guitar well
and
able to sing that song for you and play
that song for you i can sing it for you
that's not an issue but playing it for
you that's that's where the issue lies
but i will play a little something for
you because i thought why not
i've been trying to play more often to
build up these calluses
and
damn because i i tend to go like
sometimes i'll just go like a week
without actually playing the guitar and
then my calluses just go and then it
just ends up being
real painful
i'm sure anyone here who plays guitar
you know
what i mean
and especially if you i have a really
bad habit of like biting my nails and i
will bite the calluses
because it's just something to buy and
no i need to leave it leave them there
they're there for a reason
uh but yeah i'll sing you a little
something as people come in
hey gamer with malachi you made it from
the start
hey rick's alike hey mantas hey ebb
hey jandio
hey repulsive winter
[Music]
everything you wanted
[Music]
does it match up to
what you saw
[Music]
just can't
keep you warm through the stress
and the late nights
you pushed away what could be yours
oh you deserved
[Music]
and everything i wanted
everything that burns
at my core
everything i need
[Music]
everything i stifle
for the core
i don't have much money but
i have something worth
so much more
a future to grasp
if your hand will unclass
don't i deserve more
[Music]
and everything we wanted
i know it has changed from before
in our minds you planted
[Music]
a vision of a life we can't afford
we'll waste all our money on
what you have shown we'll mold it as our
own a fill us with floors
[Music]
tell us
we deserve more
[Music]
you age
did you see
every moment
was it your choice you made
to replace those who
[Music]
judgment keeps us time
to place
with
something for
my day
[Music]
there you go little something to start
the stream
i thought maybe because it's like a
game about music
i should try and just sing more during
these streams also because me i keep
being a perfectionist with everything
that i do and you know what i just got
to start having some fun as i say this a
lot thank you nelson
thank you gaming with malachi thank you
abe thank you vixelite
thank you infinite bliss
thank y'all
um
okay
let where did we finish oh yeah
we finished off
ah thank you so much came with malachi
i really appreciate that hey danny
um
we finished off
sorry spoilers wow big party um not not
about the brother tonight jeez no no
that was about the this um but no so
my brother's dead sad sad uh oh yes and
we um
we think that the the dude who is a very
bad boyfriend who i i forget names i'm
very bad um we think that he had
something to do with it because he works
at the company uh that at the mining
company that made the explosion happen
that basically led to the brothers
demise so
let's figure out what we can figure out
ah i'm so glad you like this song nelson
okie dokie let's do this
as always let me know if i'm too loud if
the game's too loud you know
whatever just give me give me a shout
let me know to know these things
continue please
[Music]
eleanor said mack is nearby
i don't see him here
maybe at the bridge
okey-dokey
oh because it says game might be a
little bit loud okay in that case
let me just turn everything down
how is this
i have to look out for a hardware store
because of puppies but i i don't think
we're going to be allowed in it to be
honest with you
uh
we've already looked at these two
so he must be down around here somewhere
down by the bridge
is that what she just said i don't know
i wasn't really listening to her i'm not
i'm not very good listen now
oh
alex i'm so sorry but before oh yes
that's so bad ah
um so i don't know how uh or has
alzheimer's and we only just found this
out because she forgot about our
brother's death which
was is quite a hard moment the chat we
were all kind of
confused we had an option of whether to
tell her look my brother's dead or to
just let
her be and not tell her what happened
but
we decided to tell her after some
discussion didn't we
and i am glad that we did to be honest i
really did appreciate your help it just
hit me hard don't apologize it's been
hard for all of us bless her
yeah it wasn't that was a tough one
he's there you can see him on the bridge
i'm just looking at all the plants first
biting my time
i'm gonna pounce
i'm so [ __ ] can't hide from me forever
mac
[Music]
okay here we go
mack
alex
look it's not a good time you owe me an
explanation about what happened to gabe
what
costing me my girlfriend wasn't enough
for you
now you're gonna accuse me of killing
gabe too
i get it
he died on your shift and you're freaked
but you have to come clean
there's nothing i can tell you
mac
come on yeah but that's something you
can tell the police
he was my big brother
i can't
something definitely has him scared
if i could just push him over the edge
he would go swimming in the water what
riley told me might do it
but i should make sure there isn't
anything i still want to do around town
first i'm pretty sure i've done
everything everything possible there is
to do i'm ready
okay
let's do this
your ex-girlfriend told me about your
plans to skip town
that's not something innocent people do
oh
god
right in there
i didn't do anything
is he angry or scared i guess a bit both
oh right he feels like everyone's
looking at him so now she's
feeling like everyone's looking at her
because she's reflecting his emotions
[Music]
hmm that's cool
[Music]
[ __ ] i'll deal with mac when i get to
him for now i need to learn everything i
can oh about everyone okay let's do this
uh
i guess the camera press that's quite
obvious
typhoon's always watching
they run this whole sound
hyphen are the people who own like the
mining
stuff and basically they're the ones
behind us but they're just a big
corporation
they're the reason why
i saw mack run down that alley
okay i thought we could look at the
woman with the max but i guess not
mac feels like everyone's
staring at him because they probably are
to be honest
everyone thinks i killed him
yeah but you're acting so shady as well
so just talk to people
it's not fair
i didn't do anything wrong
oh that's all right james no problem
this video will be up uh so if you want
to see if i do something different to
you then you can always come back later
it should have been you instead
alex
she's not gonna think that's weird at
all
oh
no what the hell there are people out
there i told you to call it off
oh so he actually did try to call it off
then
and he did i saw the way they looked at
me the wake
they all think i let him die
i know why you're lying
um
okay well we just had a little
thought of him being like there's people
out there call it off so
it seems like it's
typhoon
seems like it's typhoon and he feels
like typhon's watching him so it's gotta
be this one surely
typhoon's forcing you to deny the call
what the [ __ ]
yeah i'm not going to say you're good to
take because if you did try to call it
off then it's really
nothing that he could have done he did
all he could do so i'm just look at that
i know you tried to stop it
they [ __ ] up not you
stop lying for them
you don't get it
this wasn't some accident
i told them you were down there and they
detonated anyway yeah on purpose
why i don't know
i swear
and then i get a message telling me to
deny there was ever a call
you got to believe me
i do i did
gabe and i
we didn't get along but
i didn't want him dead
now
now typhon's watching me
my girlfriend she she thinks i'm a
murderer
my neighbors all hate me
what the [ __ ] am i supposed to do
i think i can calm him down but does he
deserve it yes
i if it's true then he really did
everything that
yes calm him down
all right
mac
come on
you gotta calm down okay
dude an antagonist
stay with me
i know what it's like
to be doubted
to have everyone think the worst of you
but the truth will come out
i'll make sure of it
if typhon comes after you they're gonna
have to get through me too okay
thanks
i actually feel a little better
yeah
being shady singer too hanging out with
french his girlfriend as well to keep
quiet so not his girlfriend
my brother's girlfriend so
what are you gonna do now
don't leave haven
i'm gonna get to the truth
[ __ ] typhon
yeah
big
corporations with all that stupid money
she needs to be around someone who's
like feeling very
calm at the moment and then she can just
be like
and suck that calmness
hey
yeah it's
can we talk
where are you
who's that
okay
does that lady who was with ducky wreck
uh
work for typhon i can't remember gaming
with malachi but maybe i don't know
i can't remember if she even said where
she worked
um
off to see birdman
i think
yes
oh he's at the spot
you were right
about typhon about mac
alex
mac got the call
how do you know that
he got the call and he lied about it
doesn't matter someone is putting
pressure on him to keep quiet someone
from the mine and it doesn't matter
okay
i keep coming here
oh my god yeah i i forgot again that he
let go of his hands oh he's not
ryan
he's dead
he's really dead alex
okay here we go
[Music]
it was my fault
my job is to keep people safe
and i failed
[Music]
oh
i don't know what to say
[Music]
he did save her
[Music]
brian
i owe you my life
[Music]
she's wrong
i let her cross that log i put gabe in
harm's way no i'm not a hero you would
have
not saved ethan
[Music]
i know what it's like to feel worthless
and helpless
but we saved ethan
and you saved me
it doesn't matter
gabe's dead
because of me
gabe
i'm so sorry
[Music]
oh i don't know what to say gabe would
forgive you i don't think i'll say i
forgive you because
i think gabe would forgive you but he
needs to forgive himself
but
[Music]
i don't know
that one
cape loved you ryan
he would forgive you
you know that
you're not alone
[Music]
oh fools why you do that
[Music]
the game was like must pause too
emotional
time out time
hold on
there's a guy in a gorilla suit
does he also jump off of the cliff and
into the pool no no he chases a guy in a
banana suit
that guy jumps off the cliff and into
the pool
okay i'm sorry this is a mexican
restaurant
[Music]
the nominally is uh
terrible
but it's gabe's favorite place
i tell you he's the oldest 12 year old i
know
[Music]
can i ask you something
of course
you came up here to tell me that i was
right about mac
about him getting the call
how did you know
i asked him
there's something you should know about
me
and it's gonna be easier to show you
we're gonna tell him about our powers
okay
this is gonna seem
sort of weird at first
then really weird
do you trust me
think of something oh i don't want to i
i want happy happy calming
you exciting about sad scary or
infuriating
great
let let's go with um
scary sad i don't want to bring back
think of something that just
scares the [ __ ] out of you
really focus
until you feel it
hey but
[Music]
what's he thinking of what do we think
he's thinking of like spiders
snakes
typhin all of it
masks you're afraid you won't know how
to handle it without gabe
never knew anyone so good at getting
into and out of trouble
oh man
this one time
[Music]
hey finally some happy
whatever it is you're thinking about
right now
don't stop okay
[Music]
keep going
[Music]
what emotion is this
it's called happiness
[Music]
[Laughter]
must be a good memory
i wonder if i can piece it together
okay oh in the clouds okay that's cute
[Music]
how deep you think
deeper than that the royal canadian
mounted police can spot a goose grave at
100 paces
the mounties
oh come on man
i'm sorry
i'm sorry how long were you gonna let me
dig
i wasn't gonna stop you
this game's for anyone hpb
come on it's 20 21 there's no gender
that's a lot of blood huh gabe this is
serious killing a canadian goose is a
violation of international law
shut up it is not their canadian geese
gabe
property of the crown
the the crown of property
[Music]
[Music]
gabe
goose
i
so
did you finish burying the goose or not
oh
they hit the goose
property of the crown
really
yeah
they are technically protected under the
migratory bird treaty act
yeah i guess it was supposed to get from
left to right
i did the opposite way around
how
i'll go for romance if i feel like it's
a fake i feel like it's good
i'm basically some kind of freak
kind of superhero
there's
something wrong with the way i process
other people's emotions
i see
these auras i guess
and sometimes
if somebody's feeling something
big
it sort of
infects me
and i start feeling it too
and
that's what you just did with
with me
yep
yep yep yeah
there's nothing wrong with you
you're a literal wizard
you're a wizard hux
it's it's only ever been
the bad emotions before but
that
that was
pure joy
who else knows
gabe did
but
now i guess
just you
and then he dies and then she realizes
that she can't tell anyone although
decided he reported gabe's call and they
ignored it
now they're putting pressure on him to
toe the line
okay but
why
i don't know yet
someone made the decision to let the
blast go off
seems like finding out who
would be a good start
so
you're going after typhon
yeah
alex big man
a woman
you'll need help
more
board of directors
you don't have to
you're stuck with me now
a big old hug
you're
welcome
i guess
yeah
thanks
thank you
no
thank you
[Music]
must be a nice relief
mean she just told gabe and then lost
gabe and now she's finally been able to
tell someone else so that's good
stage subs
yes
you save subs
alex going after the sister
oh mateo is happy that we hugged
one's for you gabe to be honest i i miss
you i kind of want them to to get
together
[Music]
how do i say
i love you
i
today
you go
how do i change
[Music]
i like it
[Music]
i didn't speak this morning
[Music]
i couldn't
hearing everyone talk about him
about the life he had here with all of
you
[Music]
i lost the chance to have that
but even though i only had one day with
him
he changed my life
[Music]
i said
i didn't know if i belonged here
he told me
that home isn't something you find
it's something you build
[Music]
i'm guessing they found the body but
they didn't explicitly say
[Music]
they can't all be feeling the same thing
surely
[Music]
i won't hold up to
[Music]
malachi maybe you're on to something
[Music]
bye gabe please don't stop forest fires
okay so
oh look look at human beings aren't we
so nice 96 of us calmed mack down from
this panic attack that's so nice of us
aren't we nicer just human beings
uh human beings um and then uh alex
reminded element i don't know about what
happened 66 percent of people did that
we do we're doing like what everyone
else don't
um 62 percent of people
didn't take typhon's money yeah i um i
understand why people would have
signed the agreement though or would
have told charlotte to do so
uh
because she
needed it to help with her and her son
but i just i just just doesn't feel
right
um alex enjoyed a quiet moment on the
dark 64 percent of people did that alex
tidied up the apartment 54 of people did
that i'm a clean clean freak
um
alex put the album on gabe's memory
table oh we could put different things
on there alex put the photograph on
gabe's memory table alex didn't add
anything
what photograph
there must have been a photograph that i
missed but we put up we brought up
something we put the album up so that's
good enough
um
everyone's a human being
yes uh alex didn't look at the dartboard
no alex left the happy face oh damn it
we missed the dartboard
uh alex chose to go alto in the lap yes
and i i wish i went alwyn
but
oh well at least we did something
different you know
um
alex spent a moment thinking of gabe yes
yes i did
alex backed ryan's claim at the wake yes
i did
uh and i'm glad i did that because it
was the truth alex offered ryan gabe's
forgiveness
yeah okay
okay yeah good most people did that yeah
i think i think it was the best thing to
do there it was difficult because
obviously you want someone to forgive
themselves
especially when the press that you're
saying oh i'm sure they forgive you it's
not here to confirm that but i think it
was a good thing to say um
ryan and alex shed a hug yeah like why
would you not hug you've been through an
emotional little time
um steph claimed the title of foosball
champion of course we're gonna let her
do that because
because obviously i would beat her but
she was feeling sad so
and steph made storm writer the lot boss
oh yes more people did that only not not
very much
um
helped with the bad watcher to find her
hawk yes well we tried but her path
finding it's so bad that she just
couldn't make her way around a bloody
bench so i don't know if she ever did
find her hawk but
oh well we tried um
alex
the sad dude find his duck that we did
the sad dude found their dog
brilliant love it
next chapter please
we're gonna start another chapter and
probably end halfway again as usual we
have a different flow on this channel
hey baggy
my credit pick is like maybe she was
holding a fart
but
wow what a song
you have a superpower
oh
okay you're [ __ ] with me right
wouldn't call it that i'm not so into
calling it a superpower but
all the rest is true
fine
then tell me what i'm feeling right now
you're feeling disbelief
i mean yeah
probably
i thought she couldn't do it unless they
were feeling really strong emotions and
actually a little honest in the powers
you feel hurt that we didn't tell you
until now whether it's true or not
you don't like being left out
well [ __ ]
okay
oh [ __ ]
the foosball game
you knew exactly what to do
sorry yeah
sorry
being around memories of gabe was making
you so sad
i wanted to help
you did
i'm just surprised
never thought i'd have a freaky empath
friend
pretty wild
[Music]
so
any sign of diane today
no but she was in yesterday working on
her laptop
you said she was afraid of something
around gabe's death
if she's covering up what typhon did
i bet there's proof
i hope so
if she comes in today let's be ready
with a plan
in the meantime
i've got to finish my shift
we're on it gotta make that down a
double dollar
i gotta pay for my rent time to earn a
paycheck
i should clean the dirty dishes around
the bar okay let's read this note
jed
thank you so much for remembering my
birthday last week and that marco
esquanda tequila was excellent
you're welcome over anytime
your best cook by a long shot francisco
that's nice
okay so what do you say there's some
washing to be done behind the bar
ah
colorado tap water
oh i miss
pubs
i need to i need to start getting back
out i need to go to pubs i'm not
convinced this is totally sanitary but
what do i
these bird washing know
even work
who's checking this out oh it's her it's
the lady with the hawk that couldn't
find her way around the fence
in your face ryan luken
better not tell ryan i had a hand
[Music]
oh there she is i wonder how she's doing
[Music]
if i can get help on my own
riley never needs to know about my
condition
i won't have to be a burden i break i
feel terrible for eleanor
and i don't think it's getting any
easier
hey eleanor how are you
i'm doing okay
thank you dear
i really appreciate your help from a
couple weeks ago it means a lot to me
you're welcome
of course
i'm glad i could help
oh i wish there's more we could do for
her
[Music]
where are you
girl from rome oh gosh
i really miss that song
they used to play it in here all the
time we will play it for you now
maybe judd knows where it went
she found the bird yes game with malachi
she found the bad happy day she found
her way down the bench all is good hey
jed where is the song
[Music]
only
so late notification come on keep up
hey
where do we keep unused jukebox cds we
don't
everything we have is in the jukebox
cool
just curious
okay so what was it something about rome
[Music]
something about
mind the day in porridge
go daddy go
mildred cross and now watermelon floss
for grade
interesting songs here
[Music]
maybe it's all i know
what
sorry steph but there can only be one
jukebox hero what was that song but wait
this
i can't continue until i find out what
the song is
where are you girl girl from rome
where are you girl from rome okay
[Music]
did you trade out the quarters in the
register yet
oh you kid
where are you girl from
[Music]
road
[Music]
maybe that one i don't know
give me your hand and kiss your hands
that's brilliant
you can play every single one just to be
sure
i mean i could
[Music]
oh
the disc is not in the machine it's
close to the cash register i think
you
that saved me a lot of time let's have a
look
[Music]
cash register
is that the cash register well that's
just
[Music]
okay we'll just walk around and keep an
eye out for it it's gonna be around here
somewhere shortly
[Music]
i can't go on a run
everyone will see how awkward and out of
shape i am
forget it oh my god that's me
maybe i can encourage her
hey can i ask you something
i've always felt too self-conscious to
try running
you seem like a pro
any tips
oh
well definitely don't let that stop you
just
push through it you
know i'll try that
oh can you stop
i think my computer always does that i
don't know why
trust me
you're not alone
and hopefully you'll now go jogging
and i'll take these off your hands
[Music]
oh there she is
hey
welcome
i'll be right with you
now i won
[Music]
i better check in with stefan ryan
[Music]
hey
do you guys know a song that goes
where are you
girl from rome
holy [ __ ] blast from the past
alabaster daydreams
my dad used to love that song
gabe would put it on repeat just to mess
with him
got to the point where he couldn't stand
to even hear it anymore
so where is it
so
what happened to it
oh eventually judd pulled it out of the
jukebox and stashed it somewhere
you could ask him chad
sweet thanks
dad
hey boss
do the words alabaster daydreams mean
anything to you
oh hell
like brother like sister huh
fine
guess it's been long enough it's back
behind the bar someplace yeah
thanks
there it is
exactly where i was looking
all right
let's hear this infamous song
[Music]
where is it the last one
[Music]
what
it's not here
[Music]
am i being stupid
[Music]
i'm just gonna press
i didn't see it there
[Music]
oh
okay is that sorry
i expected when i used it
it would just already be on the song i
don't know why
there you go
oh she's feeling happy now
[Music]
alabaster daydreams that's it how the
hell
don't worry about it
you're welcome
[Music]
stefan ryan
the newest inductees
gabe would be proud
cute
it's time to change your life join the f
growing rex the world leader excavation
money and distribution no thank you
don't want to work for typhoon
the hell am i gonna do with a jacket
that says hell divers on the back
jeez i don't know boss man maybe you
could wear it like the rest of us are
gonna do
you think i want to broadcast my
affiliation with you jokers to the rest
of the world
i got a reputation
chad's crew really
no surprise there
okay we'll go and talk to her in a
minute oh he has a plan i love you gabe
[Music]
not to be a single issue voter or
anything
but [ __ ] typhon
the spring festival is nigh please don't
die i say
the annual spring festival competition
there's games
hey ducky
it's gonna be a long night tonight
always is
same thing every year
tonight's the spring festival
wonder what's wrong
hey ducky i thought he was really
excited is everything okay
of course
i've never felt better
okay
glad to hear it
[Music]
okay i can't push you oh damn it
i should have put a smiley face on that
jed acts like he's in charge but we all
know who really calls the shots in here
[Music]
ducky almost hustled me out of my first
paycheck
good thing jed stepped in
poor emilia
amelia goenstein operated at bed and
breakfast for nine years knowing for its
beautiful rooftop garden she died at the
age of 32 of influenza i don't know if
i've already read this or not
they're married shortly after her death
the identity of her husband remains a
blistering
shooting before her death not after i
was just like how did she marry someone
after she died i started dust in
daylight while you're at work
you're kidding
i already got to verdant cliffs
wait
holy [ __ ] seriously
yeah hey
getting ready for the big larp
oh hey oh yeah
trying bells
i hope we can get ethan into it come on
see
i don't know what that succulent says
is everything okay
yeah
don't worry i'm sure he'll like it
okay we can't see what she feels right
so let's go here
if she's hiding something i need to
figure out what it is
for gabe
okay
she's here we're back on the other side
what's the plan
well
we have two plans actually
but
we're still workshopping them
what does workshopping mean exactly
it means ryan won't admit that my plan
is probably so we have to choose okay
let's hear these plans give them some
money okay
so here's what i'm thinking
i asked diane out on a date wait what
and she's so into it she doesn't notice
one ryan luken swiping her laptop
ryan carries said laptop upstairs
acquiring damning evidence
maybe diane and i still hook up
not
important that's your plan wow
oh my god please tell me you have
something better
i do
now to be clear
it's the same plan
except
i'm the distraction
look steph i don't even think she's gay
all right
she's probably into the rugged mountain
man type
ah what the transplants are
let's keep workshopping
okay maybe these plans do need some more
time
what
it's a simple plan literally two steps
you just need to choose
the hotter distraction
okay i'm not doing that
you're the only tiebreaker we have
what is alex class
no one thinks no one think alex is
having to do it
[Music]
ah
i think like personality-wise i think
steph can like definitely work her charm
i just don't know if she's into girls
it's hard to tell
she seems very straight and narrow but
like i'm sure she didn't used to be
flattered by it
[Music]
mateo wants me to choose ryan
does this influence the um
the uh love interest like if i choose
one does that mean that i find them more
attractive or does it not mean that
because i'm just trying to think about
the situation
[Music]
nah bro she swings both ways folks show
okay well
if you does then i think steph is
probably the one i'd want to go for to
be honest
i have seen
many hot straight girls who wear
pantsuits
they're actually very in fashion
yeah i think the same gen deal i think
steph could just like keep it going i
think ryan would get a bit awkward
i just think steph's better at
letting
words roll off the tongue does that make
sense
he seems more like a
candid
authentic person and she's more like a
flirty fun
winging
[Music]
i'm going for stuff
sorry
badass dj
it's a no-brainer
sorry ryan
[ __ ] yes
that's fair
look
i appreciate the
the effort
but we don't even know if she has
anything worth stealing yet
i'm just gonna try talking to her
maybe i can get her worked up and read
her emotions
i'll let you know if i need that
distraction
oh so we're not actually going with the
plan anyways what do i have to choose
then your usual
thanks alex
what's the best way to rile her up
oh i know you're responsible
i mean she already felt awkward at
gabe's wake so maybe best way is just be
like i know you're responsible
[ __ ] it
i know typhon's responsible for my
brother's death
i don't know how
and i don't know why yet
but i will find out
alex
i can assure you that typhon is
committed to a full and open
investigation yeah right that's why they
wanted to
blackmail you
and hold them accountable just as much
as you do
that's the truth
she's not getting riled up though we
need her to get fired up
so we can read her emotions she's got a
great poker face unlike mac but let's
see what she's really feeling
or does she not need her to feel strong
emotions let me try and meet her first
i'm confused about your powers now
girlie have you been working on them
i'm sick of the lies and i'm sick of
taking the heat for this company yeah
she's pissed
if i can stoke her anger at typhon
maybe i can find out more okay
is that your niece and nephew
they must be proud to have a super
powered businesswoman for an aunt
i suppose
they do look up to me
i try to be the best role model i can
do you
have um enough napkins for this i'm
gonna do it alex what are you doing yeah
i'm fine thanks
do you belong to a church around here
hmm
oh no
honestly i'm sort of lapsed with all
that
i do miss it though okay so she is a
christian woman
well my aunt william bloom huh
yeah
he's the best
good beer
yep
i can't even imagine going to
confessional now
one more thing typhon's taking from me
oh i was supposed to be reading her
emotions after everything i looked at oh
damn
ethan's a great artist
isn't he
he sure is
i can't even imagine going to
confessional now
one more thing type integrity to our
very core
what
oh
yeah that's our motto
it's
it's a motto it's a motto
okay
now i need to pick something that will
push diane's emotions over the edge
integrity
unless it gets in the way of profit
then [ __ ] integrity yep
[Music]
look i know you're not a bad person
but my brother is dead because of the
choices you and typhon made
how does that make you feel
i actually want to know
alex
i
we
typhoon is doing everything we can to
address the situation
that's the truth
you know that's a lie
[Music]
all right
that's the emotion i was looking for
time to explore diane's anger about
typhon
yes we'll do it
uh where is the dot
[Music]
okay
time to find out what diane is really
hiding
typhon brought me here and look where it
got me
damn them all
[Music]
does it fall within the tolerable limit
well
as i say in the report there's a small
chance that debris from the detonation
could it's a simple question
it falls within the tolerable limits
wait oh right something else does she
make the call then
for them to go ahead
i didn't join typhon to cover up a
murder
if they try to pin this on me i'll have
everything i need to fight back
oh
holy [ __ ]
she must have evidence on the usb stick
looks like i'll need a distraction after
all
i can't believe she feels
just comfortable with alex sitting there
after all of the things she just said to
her
i'm okay
[Music]
okay she comes
this is gonna be funny
[Music]
hey diane
oh hey steph how are you
so
what's your deal
i'm sorry
are you single
semi-single
taken but still down to get drunk and
make out it makes you pretty um whoa
embarrassing i'm not expecting that at
all
um
am i blushing i feel like i'm blushing
yeah
i could see your cheeks from space
super real good look for me
i'm so flattered
i don't even know what to say hey
no sweat just think about it
get back to me i'm not going anywhere
i mean it worked see ya
i felt good bad for her though
because that must be so nice for someone
to just come up and be like hey i like
you and you're like oh my gosh
and then they actually don't that's
really sad i don't like them
i wonder what would have happened if i
chose
which is ryan
is it ryan is
my heart is pounding
there's a very real chance that you
awoke something in diane
wouldn't be the first time
ah
you guys oh that was hilarious oh my god
i hope this was worth it
password protected
guess i'm not surprised
i'll bring this to riley see if she's
willing to help she's a wizard computer
stuff
in the meantime
we have a lot to do
yeah fun laughs
and meet me at the park
and don't forget your guitar okay
is the guitar really necessary what
how can you be a bard without a guitar
the bard's whole job is to musically
regale people
okay okay well then
prepare to be regaled
so
did you finish the thing
yeah barely it took me all night
i haven't carved like that in ages
all right i need to grab my guitar and
the hat that steph got me
wow
typhon officially clears typhon of any
wrongdoing in death of local man at the
hands of typhon explosions
if it was an accident why are you still
investigating i said about the girl at
this point is to gather enough
information to prevent an accident like
this occurring in the future accident
scare quotes yum love to lick boots
what
go back to your safe space please don't
make me disable comments
oh it's so funny
we'll be close to regular business this
afternoon in order to participate in
steph
gingrich's live action game
we'll see you all this evening
live action game what it's called a lap
dad i knew that i was missing it
to stephanie i've written an extensive
backstory from my character inspired by
sections of woochie
changing's the story to the west however
whenever i try to include it in this
application i will receive an error
message to the effect that i've exceeded
the character limit so what's well i
know what i'm doing with my friday my
afternoon can you drop off a copy at the
shop
cute ducky's gonna be there that's cute
okay
uh
let's have a look i think we got some
text oh yeah damn we got a lot of ticks
okay so we got the one from riley
okay for a drink last night
playing games together that's nice
making friends
steph
you're great you're genuinely great you
have a gorgeous voice cute
uh
jam session tonight
okay cool so they've been like singing
together and stuff
which is nice
and then ryan
amazing nature documentary
stuff is busy for the third year in a
row i'm detecting a passion here
oh we went mountain biking that sounds
fun
she's been having all the fun
mac
i rest more than just my job to talk to
you
okay
charlotte
hey what's this so if we get high and
then we start texting charlotte
uh how many gummies is too many gummies
sweetie try and relax can you tell me
how many you had
how worried would you be if i said five
gummies did you do anything else with
them alcohol other medication just
snacks take a nice deep breath take a
drink of water and lie down on your side
don't drive or do anything serious it
will pass you had a little more than the
normal dose but nothing dangerous okay
thank you did i ever tell you that i
think so beautiful
thank you just put down your phone close
your eyes hey there's text last night
with just a test did i pass with flying
colors
ironically fine colors are also what i
see when i close my eyes today that's
brilliant love that that's hilarious
oh cool we've been babysitting ethan
that's cute
we're having dinner together
that's nice
i love that they put little things like
this in as well so you get to
i don't know get to know the characters
a bit more just if you decide to so it's
nice
he's a big loser
welcome to take down typhon thread [ __ ]
yeah
it's an honor and a pleasure let's
celebrate alex's place tonight
let's break into the typhoon office in
denver what
we're not driving to denver and breaking
into a highly secure corporate office
boo
okay
cool cool cool
right that's that we've got a few bits
in the journal but
we will carry on for now because i've
been reading that for far too long now
let's just have a little look around
here first oh we got something new a
little chick mac ducky's gift to me for
finding his booze oh that's cute
um
it's
a unique expression of gratitude i love
it i think it's adorable
i know this is ethan's copy but
i'm level 73
and i'm not stopping
teenagers only
i found some really cute photos of gabe
and ethan on this thing
i haven't beat steph a single time
that just means i'm overdue for a win
right
oh sugar pie rock riot
kings of leon let's
put sugar pie ryer on
she always hate in our sculptures she
likes the one that um
is it charlotte made
[Music]
sometimes it's hard to say where gabe
ends and i begin
his job his apartment
his life here
but if there is a seam somewhere
i see it most in steph and ryan
in my mind
when we're all together i can imagine
him in my place
and i can watch the scene unfold like a
spectator for a life i barely knew
or
if i choose instead
i can forget about gabe
and just accept
however and probably
that steph and ryan care about me
for my own sake
for no other reason
[Music]
i think i know which one gabe would
prefer
[Music]
it must be weird because you must just
think you're like you know replacing
someone who's not here anymore
and
keep thinking that they probably wish
that
you know you were the other person but
no
i don't even know if i'm doing this
right but
it felt like i had to do something
that's so cute
life in haven would be a lot worse
without these two weirdos
look at them both their little
checkers
hey no a housewarming gift from eleanor
she said gabe loved these little dudes
no sunglasses though oh yeah because
you're in the flower shop i still need
to find this bloody missing
puzzle piece it's really annoying me
surely it's gonna be around here
somewhere please let me find the missing
puzzle please we're one step closer now
totally not corporate sabotage to-do
list
let's see what is to do then
figure out daniel's uh diane's deal
maybe read her
read her alex working on it we have done
that now
czech public press calls for typhon's
typhoon accident reports legal ways to
file a complaint with typhon corporate
turns out corporate law is come
complicated
well yeah contact private investigation
all three dudes have gave a crazy high
price pass research other typhoon sites
in us abroad spy on miners in the blank
black lantern
do you want me to get fired no
use the dark web to find elite hacker
couldn't figure out the dark red
take a break and watch nightmare on elm
street dan yes
request copy of completed police report
how does haven feel about typhon radio
radio paul
interesting
it would be
interesting to hear what the majority
have to say
as
alex steph told me you'd be willing to
pay play as our next open mic yes i
wager it should really help lucy fox up
and break the ice can he make it jed
there's always a corkage for you
quackage
what's that
these are the gummies oh
oh see that's great well building we
read the text and the games are right
there so it all makes sense oh that's
good well working i like this
alex thanks for the foosball game i mean
it also only eat one of these at a time
when we ate five
whoops
i still haven't gotten you open yet
must be a key around here somewhere
who's going who's going bye matio thank
you for being here you've probably gone
already but thank you for watching
wow
steph is a rock star for putting this
together
ethan is gonna flip
oh cool
oh cool it's our little sheet okay uh a
day in the kingdom of carls welcome
travellers today thana the monster slave
it's visits the trouble
troubled stone
sunborne capital city of calms
can he dispatch the ravenous monster
hoard and save the killing them
i don't know i'm saying things weirdly
la basics i love live-action
role-playing is a game in which players
portray their characters through
physical action using costumes and props
to add to the fun safety rules we're
here to have fun don't hit too hard go
for arms legs torso back sides in front
avoid hands feet neck head
act stuff out if you get hit perform a
grunt or injury thank you so much for
doing this it means a lot steph
your character name alto race heart for
elf class bard level one health points
ten
name
attacks
untuned chord effect one damage magic
healing serenade plus one health to you
and your allies staring him double
thinners next attack backstory after the
harrowing attack on the
song avari and the
amphitheater alto the bard has been a
constant companion to thano the monster
slayer the two have endured many trials
and have recently found themselves
answering a call for heroes in the city
of stonehall
thaner human warrior level one
oh so this is uh
this is the kids character sheet then i
guess
they know that monster slayer is the
most famous hero of the adaway peninsula
even the smallest child knows how he
once fell the valley bear with empty
hands and hurled a spear into the beast
of a
into the breast of a wraith mid-fight
entire cities have been saved from the
scourges of darkness thanks to thanos
unrivaled strength
cool cool cool cool
they have a little map
the mage emporium the kingsbow girl with
weather's tavern his majesty's stuff is
careful river of sorrows dangerous swamp
troll
spider with ally oh my god this actually
looks so cool this is going to be so
much fun
hey
a dire rat joined your party
yes let's get dressed let's wear
something cool
a mustache
kitties
three mustaches
mustaches
birdy faces moustaches
or just black black is nice oh kitties
that's what kitties kitty kitty kitty
kitty kitty
um
i like that we can get dressed
okay oh wait there's some more stuff to
look at
leave it to me to wreck gabe's bike on
my first ride oh no at least ryan had a
good laugh about it she would go
upstairs
there's notes here one day i'll stop
being a freeloader i push you just stop
paying rent take a few just great phone
piggy bank first then we can talk oh
he's so nice
let's go upstairs see if there's
anything there to look out before we
leave
no worries fergie thank you for coming
and watching i hope you have a good day
at work or evening or whatever time it
is i hope you have a good
time at work
and it's not too stressful for you
oh no
the plants are dying
that's water then i saw a hose yikes
this garden is looking gnarly
yeah let's do something about this
cannot let the plants die
where's the other end of this hose
to here i can't do anything about it
still i haven't played for anyone else
in years
that was a good night
so far ryan is the only one that uses
this
maybe i should just gift it to him
i wish gardening
was that quick
i realized i had um i have thrips on my
monstera plants so right now it's
outside um not in direct sunlight
because i don't like that
but
trying to treat it
and i've already had to get rid of a
couple of leaves because i cannot treat
them but fingers crossed my plant will
make it look man
if you want to live here you need to do
your own dishes
hard and hard
okay very nice
i think that's all we can do with these
plants
we did our best i wonder how many times
gabe got stoned up here and stared at
these
guessing it was more than zero
oh no don't leave yet you gotta take the
guitar
don't forget guitar
do you have a case okay let me grab my
hat i need to buy you a case where's the
hat
oh here
here this hat
hat hat
this hat
what hat
hat
i do not see hats
i still haven't gotten you open yet
must be a key around here somewhere
where's the bloody key
key or hot key or hot what's in this
chest
huh
there it is
is there a key in here oh there's a
feather power
key
okay we're gonna use that before we
leave
half person
half dump truck
i feel you secretly another one of
gabe's hidden cans
torque
yeah
i don't need to know what that was for
uh okay so before just in case that
creates like a cutscene or something i'm
just going to
use the key
on the truck
it's taking us like an hour to get our
guitar and hat this is my version of
getting ready same just getting
distracted by everything that you can
possibly see this must have been caves
make [ __ ] right list
oh that's cute
find alex find owner of stolen chevy
reimbursed jed for free rent
oh he said she did the same thing for
him as well he's such a nice person
return ernesto's walkman donate to
lawrence
detention center apologize to big new
bomb for kevin why do you keep doing
that oh my
very annoying sorry about this
i apologize to zoe apologize to era and
tell
him you like his remixes
we can do this for him surely
we really apologize at this time
i apologize to zoe
that's a long list
and i bet he would have gotten through
it
project oscar
pay mr wolbeck for the chevy apologize
to the guy from the mall white thank you
lesser seleni
mail checked in mrs franks for the
broken window she moved to maryland
track her down
write to mrs henry at buckman height and
tell her she was right forgive dad
oh bless
wow gabe
still finding ways to break my heart huh
okay
time to get this hot
i'm gonna go larping
so don't worry rick's like you didn't
finish the line you didn't finish you
didn't
miss them oh [ __ ] what
the feather on the hat must have fallen
off
maybe i can find it oh jeez this is
taking us forever
gabe's last effects from the coroner
pike dropped it off a few days ago
guess i've been avoiding looking through
it
okay now might not be the best time but
you can take the kid out of juvie
oh
you're hot hurry up and finish your
shift
okay
one match left
i don't know why
but
this must have been really special to
gabe don't give up
um
never know when you'll need a light
i'm not giving up yet gabe
i better find that feather
steph is a stickler for details
wire bead fitter
well this oh there it is
right there
okay
i better find ethan right away
not sure what laugh is happening ethan's
not into it no it sounds like his dad is
picking him up in a few hours too no
let me try to run to him i'll be right
there oh geez
alex the bard ready to serve
time to head out
not if his dad's gonna be there right
let's just go
uh yeah so i i i assume they found the
body but that hasn't been mentioned here
this bar likes cats
hey
i don't need
like
cheering up or whatever
okay
so
maybe this wasn't the most subtle idea
but
oh we're not gonna say do it for gay
because
that's just
you know
manipulating i think
i don't want to say do it for anyone
like if you don't want to do it
you don't have to do it dude
but i i'm guessing what she's going to
say is you know i wanted to do this so
eh
i'd be pretty bummed if i didn't get to
play my first larp with you
i do want to do this
it's just
not in the mood
can't force it
everyone's been working so hard and if
i'm not happy
they'll all be disappointed
it's okay
must be weird
having a bunch of adults pressuring you
to dress up in a costume and act like
you're having fun
yeah
especially my mom
she always looks so
sad
cause
i'm like bummed out
but
i can't just pretend
yeah
and that's a good thing it's a good
thing to not hold
emotions inside it's really good
yeah don't
so
don't pretend
just be yourself
or
yourself with a
foam sword and a funny hat
but
what if i'm still
you know
not having fun
then don't
that's fine too
no one will be disappointed in you for
being you
perfect can you stop jesus what is wrong
with my computer today
all right
but i don't want to do it alone
you have to help me
of course
what's a bard friend for
i am in desperate need of a great hero
could you be the one
please tell me of your exploits
oh
there's a bunch of stuff
maybe the box maybe my bar can sing
something about yeah
oh sing your heroic
tales
hoards of
ancient kraken
a kraken ate a city every year until it
died on thanor's spear
oh yeah
my goodness
so you must be feynor's bard alto whose
songs have magical powers
it sounds like you are exactly the
heroes i need
my name is king tabor
the age of monsters has come upon my
kingdom horrible creatures stalk the
streets my people live in constant fear
but there's hope
an ancient prophecy describes three
mysterious gems
known as soul jewels that can save us
all
i need you to go search the kingdom
survive whatever's out there and bring
me back those jewels
do you understand
yeah yes
yes
your majesty
good
then you must go now
okay my people are counting on you
should we start with the main road
okay
time to find some jewels
yeah
[Music]
magpie emporium arrives in the night
transforming an empty storefront into a
phoenix
maggot shop
magic supply shop
yeah okay we will go check it out this
is kind of exciting good
oh he's happy too
alex really saved the day
gabe would be proud thanks jed
please find the three jewels time is of
the essence
right get out okay we're on it
where is he gone where's that little
little dude
how do we know where to look
where are you i think we don't know
it's a true adventure
oh
can you play on swings
this is really pretty
can i go down here
what
oh sorry
apparently for some reason i had to read
my character sheet
so where are we
his majesty's summer castle also we're
here on this little little beachy bit
what do you think the jewels are for
magic ritual maybe some kind of magic
ritual
that protects the whole kingdom
does king tabor know magic
i guess we'll find out
i know we said we're gonna
take the main road but i've gone off
course oh there's a coin
what did you just find
a gold coin
do you think there's more of them
i don't know
let's keep looking
okay
it's a wolf
[ __ ] what do we do
i think we have to fight it
this is so cute i can't even it'd be so
cool to do something right there
oh cool um
attack attack
burning blade
and you're on fire for the next two
turns
let's do
magic
staring him stirring him
double feynor's next attack
oh yeah
ah two damage
no
i'm still on fire
yeah you are
this is really fun
so stupid uh so if you have magic
shield of courage nah
so he's got double attack now so
i'm just gonna stop step step
forward
damage hell yeah
oh
yeah
flute
oh cool
i learned a magic attack
one damage to allies
better be nice to thane or oh
[Music]
oh i don't know if i want to do that may
only be used once it's three damage to
enemies but one damage about allies will
it
let's keep going
what do you think this key is for
maybe it unlocks something in one of
these stores
[Music]
this is actually really fun i know it is
annoying
how do we know for sure it's dead
should we
tickle it
stop it
be serious
okay sorry
i swung over the top once
no way
prove it i'll give you a dollar if you
can
i did i don't have to prove it
i'm gonna tell my mom you called me a
liar
do it dude
i dare you
yeah everyone in life strange is
exceptionally awkward and i love it i do
too it's very wholesome it's very
different
i like it
it's extremely wholesome wholesome is a
great way to describe this game
gotta keep on the lookout for these
coins
let's go to the peach
hmm
it's cute
well now who do we have here
let's go to the fame or the monster
slayer
and my bard it's his eye
and what you have to do
saving your lives
there's monsters out there
orcs and minotaurs and
minotaurs and such scroll of healing
restores you and your allies to foul
health removes all
negative safe effects may only be used
once oh that's that's good
i'm not gonna use what is that it's a
magic scroll we can use in fights
oh
awesome
we should find as many as we can yeah
okay keep our eyes peeled for anything
i'm pretty surprised that stuff isn't
down here by the waters but
hey this is donna
oh yeah we already loaded that dollar
shouldn't go back until we found all
three jeans okay we go
what was that what just happened thank
you for
subscribing in
zilpione
sorry i probably just purchased your
name hey this is another squirrel
scroll of nimbleness plus one dodge you
and your allies will dodge the next
attack may only be used once okey-dokey
no i don't need to read it it's fine i
found a scroll
yeah
i find loads of things
this is so much fun
i like this i just want to do this in
real life it's like so sad that i can i
can't just do this in real life
maybe i can
you and your allies gain an extra turn
may only be used once
if if another coordinator is here your
birthday sounds freaking fun and awesome
i want to do something like that you've
inspired me
they did like a
taskmaster
birthday like the black
i can't remember the last time i had
this much fun that makes two of us
hey
let's hear your riddle
there are three it is said
heroes long dead
fashioned into soul jewels blue violet
red
what are their names
do not be misled
how are we supposed to know that
maybe we can look for some clues
wait j can
violet
do not be misled
nothing here
i would gladly work at a place called
gallweather's tavern
looks like you dropped something diane
every tuesday
appointment reminder
with walks like you dropped like a
behavioral health center
oh
i don't know what that means though
okay let's go in the table i want to
look in here
yeah
let's go in
what happened here
oh my gosh
fellow survivors i see
it's a gnome
are you hurt
hardly my first monster attack
i know an escape trick or two
he does it like a gnome
it's okay do you know what this key is
for
belong to barry the tavern keeper that's
his leg over there
oh
so
if you want to try all of the locks
i'm sure he won't stop you
let's see what we can find around here
[Music]
i'm a genius for convincing steph that
my character should be alone behind the
bar absolutely all the drinks i want oh
no ducky not sure how i feel about that
we're gonna have to deal with this
believe that a swamp troll has taken
residents below the eastern bridge use
extreme caution when crossing or better
yet don't
i've got a new diamond i wonder if alto
the bard would have cracked the tavern
top 20.
okay
i think steph really went all out in
here
yes
you can ask about the um
the gnome
or about the ale
oh everything
i see you've poured yourself some ale
i mean he can't be drinking all of it i
heard
barry the tavern keeper has a son
ned
was very observant
so
barry's like 100 years old
i'm such a party pooper
wanna tell him about our quest
we're on a quest to end the age of
monsters so you
won't have to live in fear anymore
are you now
let me give you something
that you may find useful
thanks i'm gonna go ahead and guess
we'll be meeting a snake
instrument requires bad effects snakes
with hearing
within hearing must fall asleep
we get loads of stuff
how did you survive the attack well i'm
not proud of it but i tripped an elderly
woman
she had it coming
stingy dishwash
we're gonna keep looking around
good luck
oh dad what
i
actually feel bad for that person
if there was a monster
rough day for barry the tavern keeper
what what do you see
someone knows how to keep thanor busy
house bard sorry steph
alto is pretty happy with her current
gig
cute black hair preferred cute smile
plus excellent compensation
all sorts of sale
repel monsters with this secret blend of
herds herbs only four gold coins for the
recipe it didn't work at all you hack
meet behind girl weathers mondays at
midnight
anyone else been hearing spooky sounds
around the castle
yes too
there's a coin here
i want to focus on ethan right now yes
you do this
is it once this kingdom has serious
problems don't write the
ba
but
for you to cut
that's an i okay it looks like a j sir
howell of graveton and gorham dank
breath tank breath love it
the 13th quincranial meeting of the
daegu biscuit boys is hereby called to
order
i'm sorry to announce that all six of us
remain upright and above ground
first point of order
ducky if you had to guess though
how much longer you fixing to live
just long enough to collect gordon and
not a minute longer
ducky is in a taunting
what's a tontine ducky is in a taunt
team what the hell is a taunting
that better be washable anyone in the
chat know what a taunting is
here we go this probably has the answer
to that riddles okay let's have a look
long ago it is said when unspeakable
terrors reigned even in daylight four
heroes faced the great shadow on the
kellyan shores for days the battle raged
until the powers of the great shadow
overwhelmed the four heroes pushing them
to the brink of death
there
among waves stained with blood three of
the heroes gave their lives calling upon
an ancient spell that put the souls from
their bodies and fashioned them into
three stones of immeasurable power
from nearer the berserker strongest of
the four came the soul ruby from desi's
the cleric weaver of stories came the
soul sapphire from bellin the
illusionist keeper of the old books came
the soul amethysts
with all three soul jewels in hand the
fourth hero took up their sword and
struck down the great shadow piercing it
with lights then weary and bloody from
the battle the fourth hero hid the
jewels away and wandered into the deep
wilds of ruin never to be seen again
interesting
guess lawrence is going to need a new
business advisor
dear lawrence i'd like to amend the
advice i gave
you when we last dined together there
was no need to sell your business i am
confident of the age of monsters will
soon come to an end i have it on good
authority that his majesty's call for
heroes was answered by none other than
they know the legendary monster sigh
monsters monsters
she has really gone all out and the kid
isn't even reading this i am
oh there's sheet music here
back then you had to sacrifice what
happened to the rest of the music
what are you talking about
new skill acquired class bag skill
hypnotic fugue
hypnotic feud what does it do though
i guess we'll find out
or we could look here
um hypnotic oh it's not there okay never
mind them
okay so did you find out anything
someone knows how to keep thaynor busy
didn't find anything
she'd not find anything with the key
[Music]
alex is right
but i was just trying to have a little
fun gotta pace out that fun ducky sorry
for your own good
i hope you find what you're looking for
thanks
okay i guess
we
haven't found anything i don't really
know you just stood over there but i
don't think there's anything we can do
here
we can come back later
bye
godspeed
check out what i found in that chat oh
you did open it
plus one dodge you and your allies will
dodge the next attack we have so much
stuff to use nice work thanor
i feel like there's more stuff to find
in the black lantern
there was some really interesting stuff
in there
what do you mean
i thought i found everything in there
[Music]
it just pisses me off so bad you know
the way this world is designed to make
you into a horrible person
that's just the price we pay for safety
and security i guess
is it
are you sure
of course that's how it works you
sharpen your teeth or you starve
you see i warned you not i wish we could
go back to the tavern when it's full of
people
sorry
we got to get back to our quest it would
be cool
okay so i think there's something here
can someone please explain why everyone
on main street is just like renee sons
festival threw up on them
ah
okay so let's keep going down here then
go get em ethan
i'm sanor
go get him
damn
yeah i bet there's something fun in the
record store
of course but there'll be something down
the alley yes
this is boring
shh they're here
whoa it's me
woe is
me behold my love has been slain by
yonder river monster
where
just down the
yonder
alley
near the river
alas alas alas
beware of river monster
all the monsters are lying some kind of
snake on it oh we have that snake thing
i guess
my god
it's so silly
i love it do we have to fight it
why wouldn't we
it's
cute i mean
it's kind of cute
isn't it
what are you talking about
it's getting an attack
what do you want to do
ophidian chime
snakes within hearing must fall asleep
pretend that's a low sound
snake's ears are internal so they can't
hear
nice
easy easy peas
all right let's make some ears please
horrid disharmony attack
three damage maybe use once for the
battle nice nice not bad and what wait
what's that we're gearing up for a boss
battle aren't we
no he's like dragons or something
maybe it's got magical powers let's hang
on to it
yeah
yeah
that was so smart of you to use the bell
it worked out didn't you
in some places dragons were just
basically snakes like they didn't have
arms or legs they were just big snakes
that could fly
wait to transfix the monsters with my
sweet hypnotic jams
skill of quiet
emini and many cannot move for one turn
oh that's good
anything around here no
and many kennel you can move forward
okay
we managed to open this last episode but
i still don't know why you actually
think the snake was cute
a little bit
yes
i actually did yes
you're weird
oh you are
that's one dodge
okay we've already we're like mr scroll
seekers yeah yep
yep
okay i think we found everything down
here
let's go into the record store
we have defeated this okay
we handled the river serpent thank you
advent
you're welcome
hello
i bet there's something fun in the
record store
no one appreciates my work
no one
oh there what's up with the brother
you've dealt with the river serpent huh
more than just talk are you
what a thankless life
being a smith in the age of monsters
whoa he's really really into this
everything okay
you seem pretty
um
grumpy
i've forgotten the damn components of
sun silver
don't suppose you know the composition
um
if we find out we'll tell you
i won't hold my breath is that like iron
or or something
okay
can i have your oh and then he'll give
me the scroll okay okay so
we'll we'll look out for that sure sure
i'm guessing this is
a fancy art gallery
wait
no a pet shop
go for it
monster
or mortal
mortal
come in
sorry about the lock
these are dangerous times
welcome
to the magpie emporium
oh
so
this is like
a magic shop
i'm going to take a look around a bit
okay
okay
cool
oh let's see what's going on so much fun
to
do hey move here sun silver
we should tell that box
a semi-magical compound using the
forging of ceremonial weapons shields
and crests weren't set sun civil can
shine with the brightness of seven suns
making it popular at coronations
weddings and early morning council
meetings components iron goblin ore fire
powder discovery of sun silver dates
back to the royal smith of griffin's
peak who first fabricated the great
sword lips now kratos under the
direction of high alchemist robert
welbert
wow
that's informative look at her she's
probably fleshing out this little world
of hers i love it
i'd like to try one of those barred
instruments please
you'll need to schedule a private
appointment
i'll do that
that's not ominous at all
the stores were killed hereby
authority authority authorizes the
magpie emporium to buy and sell
items with magical properties the guild
assumes no responsibility for the
consequences
it's dangerous
as a classically trained bard i gotta
say
this music's not bad
he's forging the sky sort of power
oh yeah
one day
thanor is gonna find it
that actually looks legit
really
it's got red eyes
golems
animation fee not included
oh steph
spells
very cute steph are these spells for
sale
to members of the
valkyrie
sorry
[Music]
dude i hear you but a combat based
system with no social mechanics is like
my [ __ ] nightmare are you
hey precious where did you come from
are you the one i've been hearing in the
kitchen you came in here
smart ass there's a cat outside the shop
the cat's got valkyrie i don't know she
doesn't have a collar
yeah
i'll call pike see if anybody's reported
their cat missing
meantime
guess she's coming to work with me
isn't she
yes she is
yes she is there you are little kitty
cat is cursed i probably already did not
i just completely forgot yeah no need to
warn me yeah she does she don't like
pets
breakup songs
uh tarot cards
what do i want inside about
things or people
two things
typhoon
haven my power my
people
me steph ryan
see my power chaos and destruction
yeah
no [ __ ]
ah typhoon holy [ __ ] i caught a power
domination
and the pursuit of the same
yeah
seems like it
let's do people
see steph steph is just awesome
spontaneity fearlessness and adventures
yes that sounds like her
uh
let's do brian is that true for ryan
inspiration i hope so for the future
that's cute
ah let's do me i really hope this is
true
that's cute
we could do all of them yes i thought
you'd have to choose
endings inevitable transformation and
letting go
that's everything
i guess some heroes are into bards with
flashy guitars
sweet silver tongue bard of champions
and savior of pinch cladman the first
okay let's look at this shop
the soul sapphire's right there oh for
sale
10 000 gold you kidding me
why is this 10 000 gold
was i too generous
it was originally 20 000 but no
i meant oh
never mind she's right there i thought
maybe we can make some kind of deal with
her
haggle
would you consider giving us that
sapphire
in exchange for something far more
valuable
my hand
in marriage
and
all of its associated benefits
uh
i mean
oh man
this just got real
i'd be lying if i said i wasn't
intrigued
but
i'm afraid i can't accept
ah
for now what
smash not good enough
matt's not good enough we need the
sapphire right away
it's for a quest to end the age of
monsters do you know how important that
is
i've heard
there's a magical fish that lives in the
river of sorrows
bring me back one of its scales
and i'll give you the sapphire in return
okay
[Music]
one
magic
fish scale impressions
already had it
then here's my end of the bargain
bob the fish did it have a name
i'm so confused i keep looking down i'm
like are they talking about the game
it's just you get the other jewels are
cheaper
okay we got
nimble nurse advantage we don't have one
of those troll dust that sounds like it
could be useful so there's definitely a
troll at the eastern bridge
three gold please
we have that
i think that's all of our money though
so the scroll of advantage basically
skips the enemy turn my hypnotic fugue
kind of does the same thing
yeah but the feel uses up your turn
so you can't attack
the scroll is stronger
what about this one so i can heal
already with my music
yeah
but the squirrel heals us completely
and it cures poison and stuff like that
okay let's get one of these
one
please i think this is all on my money
now
okay we're going
oh wait i haven't actually spoken to you
yet or seen how you think when do
did she mean it
or was she just messing around never
seen steph feel this way before she's
always so confident
[Music]
i hope we meet again
wonder if they have drills for this
okay
that's it
we're all done here
do we read my advertisement my dating
life could have used a truth spell or
two
now we can go back to the blacksmith
okay rick's like just called the fish
bubble you can do that
and john's like isn't it jim the fish i
don't know
the fish is whatever you want the fish
to be
okay
hey we found the components of sun
silver
it's iron goblin ore and fire powder
praise the gods
of course
how could i forget
why don't you take that scroll yes
oh sweet i was gonna buy the advantage
but we've got it here now i saw that
like
right before you picked it up can the
fish be my new lover you can have the
questions you want to victory no i don't
care
i'm just saying too late
credit's yours
okay
can we go in here
come on
monster abundances are when you look at
remains closed until further notice no
ah
disappointed
i thought i would finally get to go in
listen here
since you two already defeated the
serpent
maybe you can handle the troll around
the bridge oh
maybe
we shall find out trolls in my day
hey bold guy how are you feeling oh
you're angry why are you angry one two
three
i control me
one two three
i control
oh
nothing like getting pissed off at your
anger management book
i saw you and your allies have fallen i
gotta help us do you see that this
scroll first
oh no
all right
he's brave and he's honest
i wonder how riley's doing with the usb
oh yeah
don't think about that now let's just
have some fun
so i think she said that we missed her
i don't know what we would have missed
oh can we go in the flower shop
that run felt amazing good so proud of
myself yeah i'm proud of you too good
for her
mind if i duck in here a second
bart business i have to
um
renew
my
bard guild membership
yeah
okay
thank you
gotta have that shot
oh she's gone is she gone
yeah
all going
did you mean to order this twice if not
awesome
okay she's not going yeah she's there
but she will be going
because she got there
i could ask riley how progress is going
with the usb
man
small towns everyone's been going out of
their way to congratulate riley these
past couple of weeks
must be hard to find new employees in a
small town
i hope it works out
cool now nice
so eleanor is donating all those
decorations
okay
looks like there's everything that's
everything to look at
oh
sooner or later
riley's gonna figure out eleanor secret
what a piece of [ __ ]
ugh what does he do now hey riley i got
you a little going ready present it's
from that chocolate place you went to
you on our anniversary last year i
haven't been able to sleep lately
thinking about you uh out partying on
your own of course i trust you but
there's going to be a lot of guys there
and they're like oh my god
uh honestly i wish you would think about
that a little call me if you ever want
to talk
dude i i like have had the same message
when i first
yeah anyway
very annoying when people are like that
just be happy for her just be happy for
her
any luck with the usb
no not yet
it's going to take hours if we're lucky
oh
if you want to check it out it's running
on the office computer
don't touch anything
okay
so i
to do so much for you back into it
you don't have to thank me
it's the least i could do for gabe
and
actually
it's kind of fun
i didn't realize you were so she's a
techie girl is that what you're going to
school for
civil engineering
or maybe robotics
it's
a lot to figure out
kind of crazy
anyway let's talk about something else
so what not how's mac doing
i haven't seen him in a while
oh he's around
probably too embarrassed to show his
face
he gives me [ __ ] every time i see him i
can't get out of this town fast enough
stay strong
[Music]
yeah i played until dawn
i saw eleanor at the black lantern this
is really fun
she probably needed a break from me i've
been nagging her all morning about
getting one of those like medical alert
buttons
oh man
i'm gonna be four hours away and she's
never lived alone before
oh bless
let's talk later
i'll let you know if i make any progress
thanks again i'm glad we don't have the
option of should we tell riley or not
because i'd be like ah
somebody my place to say but at the same
time she needs to know
okay let's go in here and look at that
god i took that bus here
barely a month ago
feels like it's been years
riley's like 300 pages in
must be a good book
this is just
so nice
you want to get a new computer for your
fancy new scholarship if this doesn't
cover it tell me and i'll write another
check
oh
yeah that is really nice i'm so proud of
you
for spring festival these are freaking
gorgeous
okay
let's do what we came in here for i
will definitely not touch this
password check is this is trying loads
of different passwords
to try and get into it i'm sure i'm sure
we'll crack in just need to give it some
time
okay well
i'll be seeing you
how are you feeling
nothing okay great let's go
yeah i feel the same cast auras it is so
detailed
the world building is very good
i wonder what we'll find at the bridge
of flowers
let's go to the bridge of flowers i
wonder what we'll find at the bridge of
flowers yes yes yes you just said that
oh
boy
nice find
thanks
he's got like a
wrestling belt
it's the other ruby
he's got a soul jewel right there oh
oh
you like my belt
it's made of human skin
[Laughter]
what do you think we should do
we have this weird
dust stuff
troll dust
dusted trolls become very friendly
one pinch per troll no no
don't you dare just
oh
man
visitors
i love visitors
can i can i get you anything uh a glass
of marshwater
slug chips
no
how about that jewel
on your belt
sure
anything else
you want to help our quest we're on a
quest
anything you can do to help us out
i could teach you to fight like me
there you go
strike your breath we need to actually
fight i want to actually fight again
attack
three damage okay cool sweet
that was quick
why don't you say something nice
about each of us
you put a great deal of thoughtfulness
and care into everything you do
and you
see deep into the hearts of people
but you don't let that stop you from
believing in them
this troll is emo
i think that's all we need right
come visit again
anytime
only one more jewel left okay
okay
uh hey does anyone know how long the
play game thing is going on is there
some time to sign up it looks super fun
uh
sorry babe [ __ ]
that didn't take long oh dan lost one
flash drive i think i had it when i was
at the lantern earlier please if anyone
finds it get in touch with me
immediately i'm offering a reward
oh gosh i keep looking at time because i
should probably go soon but we'll try
and finish this barney business
first
i'll keep an eye out what kind of reward
do you have it no but funny in the world
i'll try a lot harder to find it
okay
oh i have a text from riley
um
okay sure
do we cross this then like where do we
go
is there anything on here
where haven't we been then yet
because we haven't been down the road
but i don't think we can go down or we
haven't been able to do that yet but
maybe we can now
don't think the larp goes that far yeah
[Music]
life without the monsters
seemed like so long ago he's so into
this
awesome
okay so we've got the magic shop
we've been there
um
[Music]
okay so we went
down to the danger swamp troll we went
down here
and defeated this one
spider with alley we went down here
got out of his tavern
dire wolf den oh i don't think we've
checked out the dire wolf den
and i think she did say that there's
more stuff in the tavern so we'll go
back
hey
you responsible for that massacre in the
black lantern
we're the good guys
right of course
we have getting up on scrolls
and it feels like we're not actually
battling anything
can we go in here
not real massacre
does he think it was real
uh okay so we've been here
oh my god i came out here hey hey
what's all this
too busy to talk right now sorry
knock him dead
ethan's back to his old self thank god
what a great kid ethan's got a lot of
people i feel like there's more stuff to
find in the black lantern okay
they say you've got
godspeed
see ya there's a person here
that i don't think we've spoken to
how do we get to them
how do we get to them
shouldn't go back until we found all
three jewels
back to the tavern it is
you find a magical pony and fly through
the sky
i mean that would be very cool
ready to answer i'll say it once more
there are three it is said
heroes long dead
fashioned into soul jewels blue violet
red
what are their names
do not be misled i would have to choose
because i can't remember
their names are lega
oh no
um
it's that isn't it the answer is mira
desus and belen
you solved the riddle you've been told
your prize a useful hint behold
to bribe that deadly troll of old you
have to pay four coins of gold
or get that you told us earlier troll
death apologies for hints too late
please take a coin feel like there's
more stuff to find
thanks
okay
so more stuff to find here
i swear we we looked absolutely
everywhere though
you're back
yeah
[Music]
i hope you find what you're looking for
same i don't know what we've missed
i wonder if alto the bard would have
cracked the tavern top 20.
oh there's a music box there's a music
box
[Music]
it's got a sleeping dragon on it that is
a cool box
feynor did you see this
that's got to be it
it's one of the jewels
that's the last one
we've got all three we can go back to
the king now okay but i want to have a
big battle please
hey clay
don't get eaten out there
we have money so we could buy more stuff
from the shop but i think we're fine
because we have so many scrolls
all right
back to the park let's do it
maybe we can talk to that guy now
oh
oh my god
it's my mom
feynor the monster slayer
you've come at last
do you remember me from your past
adventures
you're neseria
the forest spirit
you have done well on your quest
the force notices
she offers a treasure for you to claim
look
there oh that's why i couldn't go up
what is that
it's a sword in a log
from the tapestry
the sky sword
it's the sky sword of power
it's exactly the same as i draw in the
comics
it's got the pincer and the same grip
and it's got this part for the jewels
how do they do it
oh
really take it
easy to get promise me you'll only use
it for good
helping others and stuff like that
okay
they've already gone above and beyond
for this little boy
they're cute
that has been his mom who did that
because she makes the sculptures
[Music]
[Applause]
oh wow cool
oh that is super cool i love this
ah yesterday
do this
i'd love to do something like this as
well
bard
a song if you please
let's sing
to things
the prophecy is fulfilled at last
nothing or smite is unsurpassed
no here it is the big boss battle
hahaha
i almost forgot about this dude
i'll take that sword now
and the jewels
storm either the undead
i should have known king tabor was you
all along
you fools
you have collected the jewels i need and
brought them right to me
uh
encouraged we've gotten this far
we can beat him
give them
[Music]
okay oh this is so cool look at the ui
oh this is so cool um okay
so i
am going to
how do i do how do i do things
so do enter
aha
[Music]
stirring him
i should use maybe like one of my
[Music]
items
school of advantage scroll of advantage
horror disharmony
[Music]
come on say no
get
magic fire blast
sorry
worth it
scroll of nimbleness
[Music]
when is he gonna take his turn
i'll just keep going
[Music]
did i do this one already staring hand
picking
[Music]
[Music]
hypnotic feud
[Music]
music
ha ha
[Music]
why not why not
i might as well
shield of courage
actually if i use
lightning storm
death to all who defy me
curse this fire
cursed fire
let's attack
untuned chords
he's gonna take the
the final blow though oh no i do it oh
wow
we did it
i can't believe what just happened
uh
oh i can use this though uh that was
epic
that last fight was epic
yeah
but the best part was finding
[Music]
oh the siren gabe's death it's bringing
him back it's dead cause of me
it's my fault
i killed gabe
i killed gabe i killed gabe
ethan
[Music]
listen to me
it wasn't your fault
at all
it wasn't
okay
it wasn't
[Music]
oh it's so much for a kid to deal with
so if anyone wasn't here when gabe died
they were saving him because he'd gone
off uh like ran off on an adventure
somewhere and basically got himself
stuck and they were trying to help him
and that's why they were there when the
blast happened
charlotte
back here
oh cool
we haven't seen her art
station is that what it would be called
before that's really cool
thanks for coming of course
ethan's dad already pick him up
yeah they just left
i just wanted to thank you
ethan needed today
so sorry
honestly by the end
i was having just as much fun as he was
he thinks the world of you you know
after everything i think you're sort of
a zero
he's sort of mine how creative he is you
must be so proud of him
he was so thrilled to see you show up
with the sword
i think that was mostly about the sword
maybe
but i think he was happy to see you in
his world
yeah
sorry i'm sorry
i'm okay charlotte
god alex don't mind me okay just
a lot going on
i can imagine
getting ethan ready for his dad the shop
the spring festival
i'm always here if you want to talk
about anything
you're really sweet but i'm okay
thanks for swinging by i'll see you at
the festival
are you sure if you want company i'm sad
no [ __ ] don't you listen oh whoa
[ __ ]
she is not this was a mistake
where did that anger come from
oh no
okay
i am sorry but i'm actually gonna have
to leave it there
so much i don't wanna i don't wanna
leave it there but i need to leave it
there because i need to go toilet and
then i need to go to bed
so thank you so much for watching with
me it was another
longest stream tonight but it was really
fun i didn't want to stop halfway
through
uh doing the lap because that was a lot
of fun um but yeah i really enjoyed this
it was really nice just chatting with
you all as well and seeing you all chat
uh about yu-gi-oh and random stuff in
the comments
uh so yeah i'm i'm glad you had a good
time well i hope you had a good time but
it was just nice to see everyone
chatting
uh but yeah i'm gonna quickly say
goodbye to who i could see in the chat
so
goodbye rexella light goodbye sedinator
goodbye eb196 goodbye jandio
goodbye uh
infinite bliss nice stream
on that bombshell good night yeah to
come back next thursday 8 30 p.m to see
if we can make her feel better which i'm
i'm sure she will but we'll we'll figure
out exactly what's going on in her head
i imagine a lot is going on in her head
uh goodbye albion
goodbye colin williams well you're up
late
did you just make it in again thank you
so much for coming oh it's it's sucks
that you can only come at the end
hopefully
i can stream later some nights or a
different day and maybe you can come in
but thank you for making it anyway
bye
alien
cute little cat emoji you like that
um
i think that's everyone that i can see
goodbye to anyone who i have missed in
the chat and goodbye of course to anyone
who is watching but isn't in the chat as
always i really appreciate you being
here as well so have a lovely day
evening i'll see you next thursday 8 30
pm bst
um yeah bye